- ♪ MONEY, BIG MONEY,
BIG DOUGH, BIG ♪
- OH, MY GOD, OKAY.
HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
- HOW DOES WHAT FEEL?
- ME BEING INSIDE OF YOU.
- DON'T FALL IN LOVE WITH ME,
ASPEN.
- WINN?
- [clears throat]
- WINN!
- [sighs]
- IGNORE HIM.
- O.M.G.
ASPEN, CAN YOU STOP [bleep]
MY SISTER FOR FIVE SECONDS?
- WEN, THERE ARE, LIKE,
ZERO REASONS
FOR YOU TO HAVE THAT ATTITUDE
RIGHT NOW.
- LISTEN, WINNIE,
WE NEED TO TALK, OKAY?
DID YOU EVEN GET THE EMAIL
I SENT YOU?
- FIRST OF ALL, I TOLD YOU
I CHANGED MY NAME TO HEATH.
- AH.
- OH, SORRY.
HEATH, DID YOU EVEN GET
THE EMAIL I SENT YOU?
- I AM NOT GOING ONLINE, OKAY?
I TOLD YOU I'M TAKING A "BRARK"
FROM THE "INTERNAHT."
- MOMMY JUST CALLED.
GRANDPA GOOBIE IS BASICALLY
A VEGETABLE, OKAY?
HE'S A PIECE OF BROCCOLINI.
LIKE, HE'S ABOUT TO "DAR."
- OH, MY GOD.
OKAY.
- WE NEED TO EULOGIZE
GRAMPY GOOBIE,
OR ELSE WE'RE GONNA LOSE
ALL OF OUR MONEY.
- WELL, THAT SHOULD BE
THE HEADLINE, WEN.
- GRAMPY GOOBIE'S BANK ACCOUNT
OWNS THIS HOUSE, OKAY?
WE'LL BE HOMELESS PEOPLE
IF WE DON'T GET UP THERE.
- OKAY, I HAVE AN IDEA.
WE'LL TAKE MY CAR,
WE'LL RIFF OUT THE EULOGY,
WE'LL DO A LITTLE "CURCAINE,"
THEN WE'LL GO TO YOUR
GRANDFATHER'S STUPID FUNERAL.
AND THEN WE'LL JUST
HIT WINE COUNTRY,
AND WE'LL JUST GET
SANCERRE TO THE DUNE.
- I LOVE IT, BUT I CAN'T TAKE
ANYTHING WITH TANNINS
'CAUSE IT MAKES MY FACE RED.
- LIKE A LITTLE ASIAN GIRL?
OH, MY GOD!
NOW I'M ABOUT TO FINISH.
WENDALL, MOVE OUT OF THE WAY,
SO I CAN LOOK AT MYSELF.
[grunts]
LET'S DO A LATE BRUNCH.
- I'M GONNA "PYURK."
- BRUNCH IS READY!
O.M.G., CONSUELA,
YOU MADE US "WARFLES."
- OH, MY GOD,
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL.
LET'S JUST INSTAGRAMMY.
- "TURTALLY."
- BUT--UH--
- CONSUELA,
HOW'S YOUR BOY DOING?
- STILL SICK.
THE DOCTOR DOESN'T KNOW--
- OKAY, I DON'T HAVE TIME
TO TALK ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE LEAVING.
CAN YOU PACK US FOR A TWO-DAY?
I LOVE YOU.
[horn honks]
- WHAT IS TAKING HER SO LONG?
SUELA, IT'S GETTING DARK!
- SUELA, BEEP BEEP,
CHOP CHOP.
- GUYS, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE EVERYTHING WE NEED.
- CELL PHONE CHARGERS?
- YEAH, LIKE SNACKS.
- UM, I BROUGHT THE GAT.
- JUST ONE?
- MM-HMM. SORRY.
- I THINK I FORGOT
MY PUMPKIN.
- WE NEED TO BRING THINGS
THAT ARE GONNA INSPIRE US.
- O.M.G.! COSTUMES FROM
THE ORIGINAL MOVIE DICK TRACY.
- SUELA, BRING COSTUMES
FROM THE MOVIE DICK TRACY.
- [laughing]
WORD UP.
- [gasps]
WE NEED TO BRING TAMPONS.
- YES, FOR BUTT CHUGS.
- WELL, WE DON'T NEED CONDOMS
'CAUSE I'M GONNA PUT A BABY
IN YOU THIS WEEKEND.
- ASPEN, I CANNOT BE
WITH A JEWISH BOY
AND RUIN MY BLOODLINE.
MY PARENTS WOULD RATHER ME
HAVE A BABY WITH MY BROTHER.
- YEAH.
NO POOP IN THE WATER SUPPLY.
- I'M ONLY HALF JEWISH.
- UGH!
JEWS ARE A SNOOZE.
- SUELA, WE MISS YOU.
WE LOVE YOU ALREADY.
- HASTA LA VISTA, BABY.
- OKAY,
THE CAR IS NOT STARTING.
SO EITHER WE HAVE
A FULL-ON "BRARKDOWN,"
OR WE'RE OUT OF GAS, WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTALLY THE SAME THING.
- OKAY, LET'S JUST MAKE
A YOUTUBE
AND SENT IT TO SANTA BARBIE.
- TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE DIGITAL AGE.
- YOUTUBE--YOUTUBEULOGY.
- ARE YOU ON MOLLY RIGHT NOW?
- MY MO--MY MOUTH'S NOT
"WORSING" ANYMORE.
- YOU'RE SO HIGH ON MOLLY
RIGHT NOW, YOUR HEART IS OPEN.
LET'S GET YOU ON-CAMERA
IMMEDIATELY.
- LET'S KILL IT.
- I WANNA TOUCH SOMETHING.
- SUELA, UNPACK FOR US.
WE'RE STAYING IN.
CHANGE OF PLAY-PLAYS.